So, for this approval process that we're doing it looks
like when we submit the first time, we lock the record.
>> Yep.
>> So nobody else can play with it.
>> No one else can modify it
until it's either been fully approved or rejected.
>> Makes sense. Okay. And we can do,
looks like we can hit other actions there?
>> Right.
>> Okay. so, let's think about this. What are we going to want to do here?
>> Okay, so in this case, when a new
set time is created and you know, we've added
a band or a stage, we probably want to change the field once it's
been set to in review, set the status of it from New to In Review.
>> Okay. So, let's do that.
>> Yep.
>> Field update. Change status to in review? Is that okay?
>> And the field update is status. How
very cool. So specifying a field value, in
review.
>> And then Save.
>> Okay. That makes sense.
>> So, now that we have it changing
that status field, it'll notify everyone, hey, this
is why the record's locked. It's in review.
The next piece would be waiting for whoever was
approving it to actually say whether they approve
it or not, so there's going to be a
related list on the record where they can
do it from there, like straight from the record.
>> Oh, so the manager can do it.
>> The manager could approve,
yes or no, or if we had that email template set up, they could also approve via.
>> From the email?
>> Yes.
>> Cool. Okay, and approval steps, so this is just somebody saying,
this is the part of the process where somebody says, looks good.
>> Yeah. So this is talking to whoever needs to approve it, and see how
it says step one? You could add a bunch of approvers if you really wanted to.
>> Okay. But we don't, so now we can final approval actions.
>> Right.
>> Alright.
so looks like by default, it locks the record.
>> Yep.
>> And we want to, I guess, change the status again to Confirmed?
>> Yeah. Sounds good.
>> All right we did that. Okay and then we have Rejection Actions and
Recall Actions which sounds similar to me. But I guess there's a distinction.
>> So, I would say, I mean. We'd probably
want to keep using that status field to delineate where
in the process it is.
>> Yeah.
>> with Final Rejection, I would say
that would probably be cancelled because we're like,
no we don't want this anymore. But Recall, maybe we'd send it back to New.
>> That makes sense, okay. Alright. We've got our
actions all figured out, based on what the approval says.
>> Yep.
>> So what should we do next?
>> Test it out.
>> Sounds good.